disney and pixar seoul streaming on
disney plus december 25th
music is all i think about
from the moment i wake up in the morning
to the moment i fall asleep at night
i was born to play
it's my reason for living
[Music]
hmm this weed the council
is a soul missing
is this heaven no is it h e
double hockey sticks hell how
[Music]
no it's the great before
this is where new souls get their
personalities
quirks and interest before they go to
earth here we are
don't worry you can't crush a soul here
that's what life on earth is for
whoa it's my life
can you help me get back come on
this won't be a disaster that's for sure
you're out there somewhere little song
and i'm gonna find you
life is full of possibilities
you just need to know where to look
don't miss out on the joys of life
like uh pizza i can't smell
we can't we can't taste either all that
stuff is in your body
no smell no taste or touch see
okay i get it disney and pixar's soul
get ready your life is about to start
start streaming december 25th